e
la menace d'une attaque russe
est plus que jamais
envisageable. Notre envoyée
spéciale, Marie-Ève Bédard.
(cloche)
- Ce sont les héros de
l'Ukraine, on les appelle
la "Centaine céleste".
Le plus jeune avait 16 ans;
le plus vieux, 83 ans.
Ils ont payé de leur vie
leur participation à ce qui
est devenu la révolution
de la dignité en Ukraine.
(cloche)
Vasili est venu leur
rendre hommage ce matin;
il le fait chaque année depuis
cette page sombre de sa vie.
Il les connaissaits,s,s, dit-il,
il était volontaire à
leurs côtés; il a gravement
été blessé.
"Le but, c'était de foutre
à la porte ce terrible régime,
dit-il, un gouvernement qui
ne laissait pas les gens vivre
en paix. Je ne voulais pas
mo, , , mais on ne pouvait plus
vivre comme ça."
"Je n'ai pas perdu mon mari,
dit Tamara, il est toujours là.
Il a voulu aider les jeunes,
il a voulu protéger la dignité
de la nation ukrainienne.
Je ne vous cache pas que ça fait
mal, mais c'est un honneur
pour moi d'être sa femme."
Le mouvement de la place Maïdan
avait commencé en novembre 2013.
Des manifestants s'étaient
rassemblés sur cette place
centrale de Kiev pour
protester contre la décision
du président Viktor Ianoukovitch
de ne pas signer un accord
d'échanges économiques
avec l'Union européenne.
Il avait plutôt le regard
tourné vers l'Est,
vers la Russie.
(chaos)
Les rangs des manifestants
ont gonflé jusqu'à la violente
réaction des forces de l'ordre.
(tirs)
Entre le 18 et le 20 février
2014, 107 personnes ont été
tuées dans la répression,
alors que Viktor Ianoukovitch
abandonnait le pouvoir
et prenait la fuite.
(chants)
Avec les quelque
150 000 soldats russes massés
aux frontières de l'Ukraine,
les cérémonies de commémoration
cette année revêtent une
dimension toute particulière.
Même la messe à la mémoire
des disparus n'a pas échappé
aux propos politiques.
"Ce n'est pas nous
qui attaquons, nous sommes
tolérants, mais nous allons
protéger nos terres
s'il le faut", leur a dit
le prêtre dans son sermon.
"On le doit bien à ceux qui
ne sont plus là", dit Antonina.
"Les Ukrainiens ont réalisé
le prix élevé de leur liberté
et à quel point cette liberté
était noble, dit-elle.
En mettant un dictateur
à la porte avec la révolution,
nous nous sommes donné
l'opportunité de construire
un pays démocratique
et indépendant."
(chants)
D'autres commémorations
auront lieu ce dimanche,
jour officiel de mémoire
à la Centaine céleste.
En reconnaissance de leur
sacrifice ultime, l'Ukraine
a aussi instauré l'Ordre de
la Centaine céleste, un honneur
consenti à ceux qui démontrent
du courage, du patriotisme,
qui défendent les principes de
la démocratie et de la liberté.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Kiev.